e
okay good morning everybody um we're
going to open up our first uh hearing
for
today uh for those in the public it's uh
or it's 9:30 obviously you can read the
clock just as well as I can but I want
to remind people on the committee here
that are just inform you that yesterday
we s received a slug of slug of more
bills here and so we now this committee
has 21 early bills which we have to deal
with by March 6 and I was just over
talking with the finance people over in
the other building on the bottom level
there uh with Mickey and um they're
being swamped with fiscal report trying
to get them all together and uh they
still don't have the fiscal notes on
many of these bills and fact they don't
even know they don't even have all the
bills that have been released by OS yet
so um it's uh that's putting a crunch
and the time frames for submitting
legislation need to change because it's
just getting impossible for us to do
what we need to do and and get the
spreadsheets that I just requested uh so
it is 9:30 and we're going to open up HB
295 this is a bill making School
building Aid programs funds
non-aps and I'd like to welcome
representa
kahill thank you Mr chairman uh my name
is Michael kahill I represent Rockingham
10 the towns of newfields and New Market
and um you may recall last week we we
talked about HB 366 which also has this
language but just in case you don't pass
that bill I brought 295 which only has
this language making building Aid non-
laabs and and the reason we'd like to do
that is because if there's money left
over that wasn't used either uh the
community didn't pass their warrant
article or there was just some change
back from your dollar every every little
bit we can save for the following bium
could make a difference it could be that
we do a we might have a million or two
to do
a small project maybe it could even be
moved from number 28 on the list to uh
to Next in order because the money would
be there and failing that there would be
just a little bit more money to allow us
to work harder on this list which I know
you still have from the other
Bill and uh or the other list that uh
Bill we just we haven't put the money in
and any way we can get a little bit more
money into this you know as Senator ever
derkson said a million here a million
there before you know what you're
talking real money and we do need some
real money dedicated to this program and
uh this is just one way to get a little
bit more to help fix those schools that
we know need
fixing thank you that didn't take seven
minutes after all okay thank you very
much are there any questions from the
committee members yes rep representative
McGuire thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question
do you have figures for the past X years
of how much has
lapsed that's a very good question and
it didn't come to me until late last
night so I have made a request and when
I get it I will certainly get it to you
and I I know there wouldn't have been
any during the moratorium but in recent
years and perhaps you know the decade
before the moratorium it might be
interesting to know how much we're
talking about but there there were there
would have been some lapses and every
little bit helps yeah we can ask the LBA
followup please yes go ahead thank you
so um I believe that the education fund
as a whole is non-aps and these monies
come from the education fund do you am I
correct to your knowledge um I believe
that the building Aid is is separate
from the education trust fund otherwise
I my understanding was that we can't put
the Surplus that we had
bu in the education trust fund toward
any of the projects in building Aid I
mean I'm I thought it was a separate pot
of money uh or unless it's just because
of the $50 million Max which we're
trying to address in 366 that we that we
can't do it but I think it is a separate
separate money we didn't do we didn't
include uh building Aid in the education
trust fund because we had because we
already had building Aid we didn't
include an
adequacy thank you I do have a question
on that
um within the statute we have the the
wording that the upcoming projects the
next one on the list and let's say we
have $15 million left in that project
the state share would be let's say 23
million they have the option of taking
that 15 million and using that for that
project or rejecting it and you move on
down the list and you find a project
that might fit th those needs I was
under the in that's how this money was
being spent other words our our debt
right now coming up for FY 26 is roughly
and and I see the department is here uh
around um 21.8 or some somewhere in that
neighborhood and that that leaves you
know 20.1 or something such that where
we end up with about 28.9 million for
construction right I've not heard that
the money reverts back to the state I
thought that stay and maybe uh if you're
unaware of that then maybe we could ask
the department to give us some
information on that uh yes um Mr chair I
think this this was a request from our
the previous uh administrator Amy
Clark so I I uh there may be some
mechanism I know the the tail is getting
shorter and shorter which is good which
also is another means of getting us more
money ability if it's if we in fact fund
the program but I believe this uh this
was a request that this would make a
difference so I I believe from that
perspective that uh Amy Clark felt that
this uh was necessary okay thank you
forther repres
pellow thank you Mr chair um I I don't
know if you can answer this question but
um having been on ways and means I know
that there's a long list of funds that
that are dedicated funds and you can
they can be designated lapsing or
non-lps so one way to keep this money
accomplish what you're saying you want
to accomplish would be to have it go
into um the appropriation from general
fund go into a a dedicated fund
and then you can make the fund non-aps
so I agree with you know what you're
trying to do um dick and I we're just
both from Ways and Means and um we're
not 100% sure but we want to look at
that possibility to set it up that way
to achieve what this is trying to
do um I'm I'm not uh steeped in the ways
of ways and means but I know there there
are people who have an aversion to dedic
ated funds who are uh powerful pembers
of the finance committee so I whatever
way will work best that's the path uh I
would appreciate you would take are
there any other questions in that case I
want to thank you for coming and
bringing that to us I'd like to invite
the department up if they're able to
answer some of our questions excellent
[Music]
good morning excuse me good
morning Jim Carney with the Department
of Education good morning Mr Carney uh
Carney um I know you're you're stepping
into the shoes of Amy Clark correct yeah
some big shoes uh but could you help us
out a little bit on the issue that we
just been discussing in terms of laps
versus
non-aps yeah so a couple um points um
your number was correct uh the
29.1 would be what would be available if
it's uh School building ID is funded to
the 50 million uh maximum for 26 you
mentioned that um also it's my
understanding that it is from the
education trust fund that is a source of
funds for school building Aid um and I
can also uh reiterate what
representative kahill mentioned that Amy
Clark did um mentioned to me that it
would be important in her mind to have
this become a non-aps fund because the
fund currently do lapse
back and do you have uh information or
can you get a hold of information and uh
represent McGuire's asked okay what's
this look like in far as those non those
lapsing dollars over the last decade yes
well I decade I'm matter because it's
all
moratorium so going recently and then
prior to correct yeah so we received a
request uh late yesterday for that
information and so I'm working with the
director Davis on having our business
office uh get that information and 2004
and one last question for you y um from
me the others are welcome um has there
been any thought if there is lapsing
dollar available to use that to pay off
the
debt uh I can't pay off yeah that would
be a legislative decision yeah represent
McGuire thank you can you answer my
other question does this lapse to the
education trust fund or to the general
fund and and also is the education trust
fund itself non-aps I think I cannot
answer those questions unfortunately I
can't get you those answers though I the
education trust is non that's what I
thought that
raises yeah yeah Mr chair and and I
think it goes to representative
Maguire's earlier question about the
source of the funds because if the ETF
is
non-aps and and this and building Aid
comes out of the education trust
fund yeah then it's already non-lps and
so well in a way not specifically for
building aid but for for the fund in
general in general so I yeah I think
there's a lot we need to thank you Mr Mr
chairman can I follow up or ask a
different question yes you may and then
represent excuse me represent pH had her
hand I don't if she's following up on
what we were discussing yeah so I'm
pretty sure I'm I can't say 100% but I'm
pretty sure that the building Aid is not
in the trust fund this I didn't quite
hear the last part I'm I'm pretty sure
that the Ed that building Aid is not
it okay represent McGuire thank you yeah
I'm maybe I'm wrong about that that
that's what I read at some point but
anyways let me ask you slightly a
different qu question besides your
yourself um or maybe not even yourself
how many employees does the department
have that are dedicated to the building
Aid um process so I would say we have
four employees in the Bureau of school
facilities and I work on school building
Aid in part and then we have one other
employee that does uh much of the
accounting site of it and reimbursements
and so forth so and that's most of her
full-time job so I'd say 1.5
1.75 any further questions at this time
of the
department not seeing any
questions thank you thank you very much
are there any other pink
cards do you have one last comment
minutes thank you Mr Mr chair I believe
there was some discussion about being
able to pay down the debt that you the
tail and that wasn't possible uh because
of the bond agreements that you can't
just pay it off and be done with it as
be anything is
possible okay we're seeing that in our
whole society here today right well
certainly I I see you there thank you
thank you further further questions
on for the testimony okay we're going to
close this down and we can't start oh
represent dick looking at the
uh thank you I was just looking at the
um education trust fund statute and just
to say that it does have as one of
its um compartments subc compartments uh
dis to distribute School building Aid to
school districts pursuing to the general
statute so that's there I I don't know I
don't know how it's used
but yeah we we'll ask
LBA that's what we got to do allowed
yeah exactly okay we're this I don't
have my G I gave represent Cordell the
other day but uh so we're closing down
uh this hearing and we'll start the next
yeah if I get a
response on on all these we're going to
have a work session um we we just got to
get through these early bills get them
heard and then get the work sessions
going on these various topics and that's
going to take a lot of work and a lot of
time I was up to one o'clock last night
working on this stuff and it's it
there's a lot of lot of ends that have
to be tied together here so so we're on
so I think I
read
e
was at Prime sponsor of this bill last
night and he's expecting his first son
or daughter to be born today and so he
said he could not make it so so what we
yes would you please do that represent
chire not that I've read no just just
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is Dan
McGuire and I'm happy to introduce House
Bill 237 prohibiting the use of special
education State funds and differentiated
Aid special education funds on students
not receiving special education
services
um yeah I I actually did read this bill
so I could say something about it
because it didn't strike me as um
well McGuire if you want to start
presenting oh then I can't sit then you
can't talk up here so I would just
introduce it and say I'll sit down okay
you're more than
welcome we don't want to go down that
rabbit
hole alrighty um are there any people
have pink cards for this I think I might
okay did you get get a pink card for
rson
Maguire
oh we need to do that because he
introduced it okay I'll just leave this
one then okay uh Becky Wilson from the
Association good morning chairman lad
and members of the committee uh for
those of you I haven't met previously I
am Becky Wilson uh director of
governmental relations for the New
Hampshire school boards
Association uh we are opposed to this
bill the way that it's currently uh
presented we feel the bill is perhaps
unnecessary it's also unclear as to
exactly what the sponsors of this bill
are trying to formalize uh we certainly
want to be sensitive to the underlying
concern of making sure that students
with uh eligibility for special
education are receiving the services
that they need in order to make
appropriate progress but we're not sure
this bill is something that can be
implemented to really meet the spirit of
that um it's a little bit questionable
from our first reading about whether or
not this is just for the differentiated
Aid um adequacy monies uh those as you
know are provided to districts quarterly
as a lumpsum payment it's not parsed out
in terms of this is your base adequacy
Aid this is your differentiated Aid um
it's based on your admr um those
adequacy monies are used throughout the
operating budget uh for the district
it's fairly easy for people to see the
line items that are within a School
District budget that would be applicable
to special education those are primarily
your 1200 lines in most operating
budgets um while a majority of the
operating budget for special ed would
include staff or specific training or
curriculum for specially designed
instruction there certainly are things
such as specialized
Transportation uh training for regular
education teachers to be able to
implement required aspects of a child's
IEP perhaps staff who work primarily
with students who are eligible for
special education but may also share
some aspects of their time with students
who are not eligible or maybe not yet
eligible um as you may know such as a
school psychologist um those people may
be funded partially um in the operating
budget with differentiated Aid monies
although it's not parsed out that way in
terms of budgeting um but they may also
work with students who are not eligible
for special education uh we also have
students who are referred for special
education who technically would not be
considered students for special
education at that time but whom special
education staff would be working with
them to do the evaluations and determine
whether or not they are eligible what
would that mean for those staff um
evaluation tools things like that it's
also slightly unclear if this would also
apply to any other grant funding it does
say adequacy grants specifically but is
there any aspect of this about the idea
grants that are given to districts um
how those are used those activities are
already all approved by the department
of Ed um to make sure that they are
approvable eligible activities um as
related to special ed in the district
and I'm happy to answer any questions
thank you very much other questions yes
represent luno thanks very much Mr chair
thank you very much M Wilson how do
districts currently track the use of uh
Revenue
dollars thank you for the question um
you know certainly Revenue that comes
into the district um as you've all
passed recently you know needs to be
posted on the district's website in
terms of what revenues are coming in the
majority of revenues so to speak in the
operating budget I mean those are all
included in the day-to-day budget the
school board has to sign off on that
monthly when bills are being paid Etc
through payroll and things like that um
is there a specific question about
special ed funding yeah yeah so so
thanks so so so I guess um use of of of
let's say in this case State revenues
that were associated with a student um
as part of the adequacy funding formula
so we're talking about the
differentiated Aid um you know in the
adequacy funding formula um do we do we
track state or you know revenues that
may come from any Source state grants
federal grants um um local taxpayers
that may may have arrived at the school
district because of the funding formula
and a and specific students you know the
me members of the admr um do we track
that down to that level so that we know
that those specific dollars uh would be
spent on those specific students thank
you for the question I think I think I
understand what you're asking
differentiated a is not associated with
a specific pupil identifier or anything
like that it is based off of numbers in
your District under the assumption that
certain districts who have certain
numbers of students who are eligible for
certain supports and need more resources
as a whole and the in the community it's
not a pupil specific dollar amount that
money is not assigned to that child so
to speak it is part of the larger
adequacy payment a quick follow up on
that yes and thank thank you and and is
it um um is it I guess your your
impression um that that at least those
at least those dollars that are that are
that were you know that came through the
adequacy funding formula as a result of
special education differential Aid that
districts are spending at least that
amount of money on special education
thank you for the question I think that
this committee has spoken extensively
about the cost of special education as a
whole and what it costs what the average
cost is to educate a child with a
disability what is the is far more than
what the adequacy and the differentiated
Aid payment is for those
students thank you and just as a
followup to all this the differentiated
Aid monies within the adequacy formula
are not targeted money
non-targeted so it may say for special
ed or elll or
fnr no it's not targeted to one child
it's targeted to the whole District to
Ames uh isn't it true
that uh special education
services uh apart from those that
involve actual separation of a child by
necessity into a different environment
are at the that the integration of
special education into regular education
is a core element of special education
and has been ever since the Ida was
enacted um back in whenever it was 70s
um and uh and almost by
definition if extra costs and there are
extra costs to have an A in the
um will
necessarily involve other children who
are not special education children along
with children who do have
IEPs um so that if the practice that
we've heard about of not separating the
money is entirely consistent with the
purpose of the special education
law thank you for the question special
education Law requires that IEP teams
Place students in the least restrictive
environment that is appropriate to meet
their needs and for the majority of
students the least restrictive
environment is the general education
classroom so yes there's a lot of um
attention and funding and planning that
goes into trying to create a general
education environment that is accessible
for all students sometimes that requires
Staffing sometimes that requires
training sometimes that requires a
certain type of specially designed
instruction um all of those things again
are not tied to an individual student
per se even though you know there may be
five six 10 students in a classroom who
could benefit from that it's also
benefiting a strong General Leed
curriculum across the
board thank you you're welcome are there
any further questions we do have the
department here too that might be able
to give us the technical support
represent
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
being here to help
us so would it be
a concern if this legislation were to
pass that we might not be in compliance
with federal law if we in order to
comply with this separation of special
education
funding would that decrease inclusion
and mean that students would not be in
their least restrictive
environment thank you for the question
it's I think that's hard for me to give
a clear yes or no answer however I will
say that if T money become student
specific a that would be a privacy
concern I think to some extent
especially in a smaller District where
perhaps there are not um a large number
of students who would be accessing These
funds in the same way that you might
have in a larger District I'm not sure
how you would protect a students um
privacy in terms of whether or not they
are eligible for special education um in
addition I
think it would be very difficult for a
school district to
parse out a you know Staffing things
like that if it's a very student
specific money I mean at what point do
you say to that staff member okay your
time is up uh based on this funding for
the day like move on to something else
and that money is going to come out of
some other aspect of a District's
operating budget I'm not sure how that
would be accounted for I think or to
meet the spirit of I what I believe this
bill is trying to do which is to ensure
that students are getting services that
they require those services are going to
be required regardless of where the
funding is coming
from thank you very much and when we get
down into the specifics on idea and what
it can be used for we're gonna I'm going
to those questions I'm going to parcel
over to Melissa white if Melissa if
you're able to come up
after Becky here but is you pardon
me for for Miss Wilson yes go ahead so
thank you so this is about the first
section only which is the special
education Aid which previously was known
as catastrophic Aid and I'm thinking
that we don't need this paragraph at all
because that's a program that
reimburses expenditures that were
previously made which were only made for
special education students stents and
and for a student to qualify for this
their cost has to be three and a half
times the state average cost which is
thousands and thousands of dollars so we
would not need this paragraph at all
would you agree with that thank you for
the question I would agree that students
who are not eligible for special
education would never be included in the
special ed Aid or the catastrophic Aid
category for
reimbursement thank
you yes
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I'd like to go back
to the um previous question not this
last one that you answered the one
before that where you commented that um
and I'm not sure I understood where we
were going so I apologize you commented
that we wouldn't want a teacher to stop
teaching because they've run out of
money um or something to that effect
right is that really the case the way
I'm understanding this bill is that the
special education funds would not be for
students not receiving special education
services so where would that instance
fall where somebody would have to stop
their instruction because they've run
out of money uh based off of what you
were trying to explain to
us thank you for the question there are
there are situations where um again this
money is not parsed out when it comes to
the school district in this manner and
being a student specific pot of money um
so there are staff that are used perhaps
in the regular ed class classroom to
teach not only special education
students but perhaps a small group of
students of which some of those students
are eligible for special education and
are receiving their specially designed
instruction within that group there may
also be other regular Ed peers in that
group because that is the least
restrictive environment for that for
that student who is getting those
Services I think it would be very
difficult
to adhere to the spirit of what I
believe this bill is trying to do which
is at what point do you say that those
funds for that staff member are being
used for students outside of special
education if you're not only solely
teaching special education students
which would be very restrictive for most
students to pull them out of a situation
where there are regular Ed peers and put
them in a group with just other eligible
special education students is fairly
restrictive you're
welcome just go
ahead thank you Mr chair so for the
second section we're talking about
adequacy Aid and the reimbursement under
current adequacy aid for a student that
has an IEP is 2 TH or close to this I'm
reading it out of this book
$2,100 per student do you have any sense
of how much it costs just to develop an
IEP for a student and then that also has
to be renewed every year correct so just
in term staff time and think it adds up
to quite a bit
so that wasn't that question know I
would agree I most Staffing for an IEP
team meeting which is a required meeting
has at least four to five staff members
at a given time most special education
staff because of some of the other
special education aspects like Medicade
and things like that you do figure out
everyone's hourly rate I can tell you
that the $2,100 would be rather
quickly
2180 okay yes
projected yes a quick one then I would
like to get to the department because
they're going to have the answers that
we
need yes I from the
director she talked about coordinating
early interven Services what if you to
talk about that and is that in essence
applying the entire
Provisions specialed to every single kid
at some point just as a monitor thank
you for the question um early
intervention services and early supports
and services is a SE a category of
special education that is required for
students well children who are receiving
community- Based Services such as
through Community Bridges or their other
Area Agency they've been um they've met
a certain criteria prior to age three by
a community agency saying that they need
extra support and service
those students um the community agencies
have to tell the school district when
that child turns 2 and a half that they
are coming up to age three and the
district has a responsibility to
evaluate them based on School District
criteria about whether or not they would
intervention thank you very
much by the way represent uh represent
Wilson Becky Wilson has been a director
of special
education uh I'd like to have have uh
Melissa white come up and Melissa we do
have some questions maybe you could
start out with
u getting into the issue of
idea and the federal law with those
monies are coming down to us have some
permissions by federal code or it's
maybe it's law I don't know uh that that
monies can be
used after school or for other programs
where there may not be special educ
maybe remedial children there uh are you
familiar with where I'm going um so MOA
white division director for learner
support at uh New Hampshire Department
of Education so just to be clear special
education
Aid those funds have to be spent on a
student that has an IEP we receive the
actual invoices for services we look at
those invoices go into our Nessa system
which looks at the students IEP and we
were able to see this service that
they're requesting funds for is in the
students IEP so special education Aid
those funds are not being spent on
anything but what's in the formula
specified in law for that student
special education needs so there's you
know this section in here regarding
special education Aid it's not happening
it can't happen it's very clear
already with the idea funds the federal
law does allow out for certain
percentages to be used for what could be
considered um not remediation but more
like mitigation and and uh kind of a
tier one or all student services
however we're pretty stringent upon if
you're going to use your funds for that
type of an activity and the FEDS are
also very stringent on if funds are
going to be used for that type of
activity you have to do a lot of data
collection you have to do your needs
assessment you have to do um kind of a
baseline collection of data to look at
okay here all the students and here
where their skills are now now that
we've instituted this program that
serves all the students this is how it
has helped us to reduce maybe um special
education identification or redo
something so it requires so
much um analysis and work schools rarely
tend to use it for something like that
because their special education costs
and needs are already um pretty clear
that they're using those just directly
for serving those special education
students so so there it's in there but I
will tell you that I I mean going down
that route rarely is it happening um
because when a school submits to us how
they want to use their idea funds and if
they're saying oh okay we want to do it
for an after school program we're going
to be very very strict about okay you
need to provide us data on every single
one of those students students how this
program is supposed to help um special
education students specifically and they
tend to not do that because they have
other federal funds they could use for
an after school program so just to to
follow up on that I'm not talking about
the whole program but for mitigation
factors regarding some children I as an
administrator there are a lot of Hoops
but federal law says you can do this
uh so by this legislation right here
that would take that little tool out of
the bag that we couldn't do this I don't
think so because it says that it's
specific to special education state aid
and it's specific
to Grants distributed to M
municipalities calculated persuant to
RSA 1984a to uh Roman numeral 2D so that
is not related to
idea that's adequacy
that's State
funds that's my understanding okay are
there any other questions for the
Department on this right now yes
represent McGuire uh thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question so more big picture my
understanding is total cost of special
ed Statewide is 900 million plus per
year and um the amount of money that
would be under this restriction is way
way less than that right so the chance
that that um in some particular
School uh they're getting more of this
money and and spending less than that on
on on special ed is is either can't
happen or is extremely unlikely is that
correct it's extremely unlikely all
you uh well while we are here then uh in
term terms of the special education
Aid previously catastrophic Aid um
the there is a separate pot of money for
that we've just heard the $34 million
which we appropriate and we've spent or
we have requests for approximately 51 of
that so we have $17 million
shortfall that money and the
differentiated Aid money the 20 1880 per
pupil
um is catastrophic aid used for any of
those students that may
also be in a
classroom for less than 20% of the time
but enrolled in the school or is the
school using catastrophic aid for
reimbursement of that program you see
where I'm coming from I think I
understand special education Aid can can
be used for a variety of services it can
range from maybe Transportation needs it
could be for out of District placement
needs it could be for specialist needs
so it's going to vary what the most
important part is is that it's in the
students IEP so we don't necessarily
look at percentage of the student the
time is spending in the classroom or
specifying it that because it doesn't
get into that spe level of specificity
in the admin rules or in the RSA what we
look at is is it in the students I AP
collectively the cost the district has
we look at the formula and then that's
how we make our
determination there is this concept or
understanding that cat special education
Aid is used for residential placements
for transportation associate as well
homebound
504 or possibly a
hospitalization uh so are we using
catastrophic Aid to support student
students which are in the classrooms are
are are schools collecting that money uh
to of course they have to spend over
$70,000 before they get anything in
anyways it's a wide range of services
but it has to be in the students IEP so
whether it's for a specific student that
may have an out of District placement if
it's for a student that hasn't it's
there in the classroom but needs
additional Services it's as long as it's
in the student
IEP that's what we look at the costs if
they were um putting them for some sort
of cost that would not be allowable we
would just you know and we do get that
we do get here's our submission of costs
we would like you to reimburse us for
and then we go through every single one
of them and then say okay these are the
ones that are actually allowable and I
guess at least to my what I'm trying to
find out do you when you're looking at
these requests for funds say no you
can't touch this pool of money which is
catastrophic Aid ESP education unless
the child is homebound
504 maybe not 504 but hospitalization
residential no because that's not listed
in the RSA or in the administrative
rules so it's all costs associated with
special education Aid it could include
those but it can include other costs as
well we don't say it's just for these
specific type of students or this type
of student that has this specific
disability we do not do that okay thank
you that gets
further questions of the
department well thank you very much are
there any other pink cards for this
particular
bill then we will close the
is 10:30 and we're going to have to roll
Mr chairman I I believe that clock is
fast it's actually 10:27 so I don't want
to push us into an issue where we get in
trouble no well we have different time
zones in this building you understand
understand you go into the office in
there and the clock is different you go
in there it's different you go next door
it's
different so so we have the fudge rule
around here if it's pointed in the sort
the right
direction South then we go for
it
yeah but at any rate um I'm going to Dan
yeah I gotta introduce this would you
chair
it let me get my garbage out the way
yeah oh they're not up there it was
originally in that policy oh so
okay we're going to we're does who's
missing these P the the bill itself
right
now so we'll we'll hold off a second or
two until we can get that let me explain
to you What 354 is um 354 is a bill that
looks at Pathways for in Career
Technical education to obtain
alternative certification different
Pathways and um if was it's referred to
this
committee because it's a Career
Technical education bill there's we'll
get some bills in that do not have
Financial notes on them uh that're not a
funding issue but if they G get into two
different categories higher education or
Career Technical education they come to
this committee
automatically um it's just we Define
that area policy where that area of
policy is
in the hands of this committee and then
anything that has to do with funding
issues that usually gets about $10,000
per fiscal note they'll come there as
well so that's the way how they when
they're saying you go here or you go
here with the bills this is how they're
doing
it so we'll wait a few more seconds I'll
go get myself planted and this a copy of
[Music]
glasses go ahead start okay so the time
being 10:30 we will um open the public
hearing on House Bill 354 and recognize
lad thank you very much representative
McGuire and members of the committee uh
for the record my name is Rick lad I
come from hail New Hampshire and I'm
here today to introduce 354 which is a
bill that uh relative to the alternative
certification Pathways for Career and
Technical education instructors um also
sitting behind me we have the director
of this program from Department of
Education and then we have folks that
are on The Advisory Group here or have
been on The Advisory Group and and uh
prior directors of director of the
conquered CTE Center um I would like to
go ahead and start this what this bill
does we have in rule right now in 50
5.01 parentheses
G um language which is very similar to
what you're seeing here very very
similar the only difference is now what
this program does it provides an
alternative route for those that are
going to be instructors at the Career
Technical education centers in specific
trades content areas to seek this path
where you don't have to go through the
same path that if you're going to be for
example a teacher in a riger classroom
or Elementary or middle school classroom
or high school
classroom and it allows us to
incorporate the in the training and the
knowledge and the skills that have been
acquired through working in the field in
their specific area they come with
credentials that have maybe been offered
by Ford Motor Company
or as a mechanic or uh credentials that
come in from uh working in a lab
robotics area and they've been working
there so they can come in and start
teaching this or if they're coming in as
an experienced welder and they have that
from the American Association for
welders so what we're trying to do is
because there is a very uh I would say a
large shortage of the skilled people
necessary for our trade in for the CTE
centers and we're in competition with
you know folks so we're there's also a
pool of retired people out there that
have all this background information
that we can tap
into um so um there's a lot of
experiences we've encountered our
information that's been provided to us
on the uh advisory Council for his
career technical
education and I can recall one down at a
school on the southern part of state I'm
not going to mention which one but they
had a person already to come on board
just before school started in the it
area and that person was all of a sudden
offered a job out in the midwest which
almost tripled his salary and so he
didn't so we had a hard time finding
somebody to come in and fulfill this job
because we had certain Hoops we had to
jump through but there were people that
were had the adequate knowledge and
Concepts to do the job so with that I'm
going to get in a little bit here on
specifically what the differences are
between the bills because there's only
in only a couple words which are
difference between this bill and what we
have that's in rule right now that's
been provided approved by jel car
um the jel car approved rule
505.01
saying a fulltime if you have full-time
experience you and be working up the
full whole time 40 hours a week or more
then that's one of the qualifiers that
you could come in on this alternative
pathway the alternative pathway requires
three years of professional paid
full-time experience in the area for
which the license is sought a current
industry recognized credential approved
by the department in a published list of
acceptable credentials there's two areas
right there so the the rule currently
says 3 years of full-time experience
this bill right here changes that to 3
years of professional paid full-time
experience and that's an that's an those
extra two words
um professional
paid if you look at RSA
193 excuse not 193 uh 21 and9 I'm used
to saying 193 for just about everything
uh 21
and9 and get down underneath the rulle
making authority of the State Board of
Education they have rule making
Authority for the
qualifications of employees that are
working in the classroom of course they
do but it reads qualifications and
duties of school administrative unit
professional employees SAU professional
employees they say professional
employees going on
it says professional preparation
standards and approval of professional
preparation programs for educators
teaching and postsecondary institutions
as authorized by the RSA the word
professional is very very important and
I'm going to give you a couple examples
that I was trying to think how would I
go about saying this last
night and I'm going to just read several
examples might for your consideration
that might help you understand what
we're trying to drive for here the first
example full-time experience may be
working full-time 40 hours a week at a
gasoline station pumping gas or working
full-time 40 hours per week washing cars
at a car wash that's your
experience now professional paid
full-time experience may be working 40
hours a week that's similar at a toota
dealership as a Certified mechanic
having completed a training program and
possessing certification test done by
toota Technical Training and education
nwork they education Network and it's
parentheses
t-teen they're coming in with that
certification whereas the other person's
doing that work you might be doing this
work at home for yourself as your hobby
and that is that going to be three years
of experience no we want to elevate the
standard for these people that are
coming into CTE so it's a standard where
we have have a list of approved
certifications which were going to allow
you to come in with three years prior
experience and that's done through three
years of Prior paid professional
experience and so what this bill is
trying to do is provide this alternative
pathway so we can get these experienced
people into our they may not have the
certification or gone the certification
route that for example I went through to
get my certification to be a teacher in
the classroom but they're coming in with
all this other experience is that
equivalent I would say in the in CTE
centers that's more than equivalent that
even surpasses that's what I want to
have I don't want to have PhD Mr Brown I
want to have the Mr Brown that has the
experience and the knowhow and how to
turn that wrench or how to work in that
kitchen and and so uh that's what we're
doing it's just trying to tighten it up
and put what we have in rule into
statute but changing the rule slightly
to say rather just full-time experience
which we have in rule we want to make it
with the professional paid
fulltime and I will conclude with that
because there's others here would
probably want to speak on that um thank
you but I I don't have any pink cards so
if anyone else is going to want to speak
on this please get us a pink card
otherwise these this is your chance to
ask questions I'll start with
representative Mahan thank you
representative McGuire um representative
lad I just have one question is a a
French a person who's fluent in French
is he included in what you call career
type of thing is is the French language
because of the dir of language teachers
in the schools is it possible that the a
French speaking person can be included
in this and let me let the second
question then I'm done um say for
instance you have one who graduated from
the sorun system uh and he is absolutely
fluent in French qualified by the French
system and and certified there but he
hasn't been paid because he was a
student is there any way he can be
included in this bill this is only for
Career Technical Education Centers
you're going to be teaching French at
the high school now there's a prior High
School teach uh vice principal sitting
behind me from conquered high he may be
able to answer how you know and he's
been a director of the CTE program for a
number of years now he's retired making
some real bucks uh so but he may be able
to answer that question for you but I
would say no that that's not what the
CTE Center is I don't believe there's
any clusters or programs within the C
French thank you thank you um
so I what I understand is that both A
and B would be
required yes so they need to be
professional and they need the
certificate um does that list of
Industry recognized credentials that
already exist is there some list
somewhere the the director of the
program is sitting here in the room as
well so you know I don't have a list in
front of me because I'm not over doe but
yes there is you know if you were talk
to Mr applebe too who is in charge
licensure over there there are programs
which they've looked at these type of
credentials they are doing that
currently I met with him this morning
that was a question I did ask him and he
says yes however we also have the
director here well the reason I asked
him because he left no Financial note
and I
thought to
be
um there is no financially you're
correct this is one of those policy
issues that if if the list needed to be
made then there would have been a
financial
right if that research had to
happen that might be a question for doe
because yeah yep yep other
questions yes representative culc thank
you very much Mr chair um in in
reviewing this I love the idea um when
you're talking about the 3 years of
professional paid full fulltime
experience should we also be thinking
about adding in a licensed professional
so if they are a welder they're a
licensed welder um or are we getting
away from having them carry their
license on through this teaching
program The lure in many of these uh
areas are issued by various professional
associations um and the certification uh
so again I I think you're getting to I'm
not a director I think you need be
asking the people that are running this
program that question behind me it's a
good
question thank you all right let me ask
a question I want to ask about a section
B here uh certified credential so I was
a u Computer Engineering professor and I
got my job based on my degree but I
don't know that in my field or in the
general field of of software development
there is such a
credential available to someone you see
what I mean I I'm not sure this applies
necessarily to all Fields what do you
think I would talk from a historical
background when we were just coming out
when we had the rudimentary
computers uh desktop and Microsoft had
some credentials which they issued
however since then I I'm not aware and
there probably is you know it's a field
that's just
mushroomed
uh I don't have a total answer on that
one at one time I knew there were
credentials issued by Microsoft and they
had training and professional
development for teachers for their
specific product for their specific
product yes their applications yes all
right thank you other questions no all
right well thank you very much
representative and I do have another
pink card
now from Steve uh thanks Steve rberg I
guess um he's representing his company
yeah I'll clarify which we'll find out
what that Rick Rick Rick spoke very well
of me I was the CT principal in conquer
for 14 years I retired a couple years
ago um the other thing he said is I'm
making tons of money that wasn't quite
accurate but we we'll leave that aside
um so presently I did start a company
called Rothenberg consulant group very
original name um and I service is the
reason my relevance for this committee
aside from my background is I have a
contract with the State Career and
Technical Association and I service
about 95 to 100 teachers at any one time
who would be affected by this bill so
every any Career Technical teacher in
the state with my contract they contact
me at the earliest stage of interest and
I bring them through a three-year plus
process of getting certified so I'm on
the front lines all the questions you've
asked I'm on the front lines of those
questions right now so I wonder if I can
just address some of the questions and
help Rick out a little bit the question
about lure totally relevant but the
common denominator is years in the field
so uh a a plumber or a licensed plumber
or a licensed cosmetologist or a
licensed um um electrician would
generally also have those three years in
the field so there's very very few
licensed professions that would affect
Career and Technical education so that's
probably why licensing wasn't there the
key was it the the key is that they're
authentic they've been in the field
they've been working with people you
know and using your example as a
Professor um the the two things were
said first I want to address the
certification piece so if you entered
care technical education and you became
a you be you really would fall under a
very large sort of area for
qualification it's not like uh you're
going to do uh just one thing so there
are certifications and a wide spectrum
of them in that space um that uh range
from programming to network routers to a
variety of things of that sort um the
the scope of it there's a list in the
state going back to your question
earlier there's a list already
pre-approved that was built in
partnership with the uh Department of
Education as well as the uh director's
Association and the state has been
exceptional in their open-mindedness to
look at other ones that are not on the
list you have people who come uh from
HVAC careers and they have some Nuance
training dealing with HVAC units that
the state even though it's not the list
they accept it is this common sense they
they've demonstrated their expertise um
as part of the mix um but there's a this
is a major road getting in and I I do I
do support the bill as mentioned uh just
and really what in reality of way the
Rick explained it that word professional
um sort of has been the operating model
so far this is some of this stuff is in
rules with the with the Department of
Education so everything sort of being
talked about today is already happening
this is not a new space a lot of this is
is in place it's been mature it's been
going for decades this is not just a
couple of years but a long long time
what's nice is to see it codified uh in
statute um so that it becomes sort of
part of where we are and who we are but
uh it's a remarkably positive piece of
the puzzle um it you have to I think the
last thing this morning I was writing
job descriptions for the new uh
winnisquam Career and Technical Center
and they've got to attract a machining
person and a cosmetologist to come work
there and I think the main my last
message and I'll take any questions is
you have to sort of understand the
cultural shift to attract somebody to
leave industry and become a high school
teacher it's it's night and day might be
a two week of an analogy um and so how
do you sort of convince them and what we
know is that um they're educated they
have a ton of experience in the field
they're going to bring a lot to students
they need a ton of training you know to
become Educators but the system has set
up that um they demonstrate the fact
they basic skills they demonstrate they
have content knowledge they demonstrate
the law enforcement that they're all
cleared they have to go through a hiring
process um and then they get in there
and they need a ton of training but our
job is get them in
there all right yeah that's training ped
pedagogical training yeah all right over
um so uh the question I had was about
actually about pedagogy so this is an
alternative pathway so would it be like
all three all four kind of yeah so if
you go back to the old days you call it
all four now it's called sblp site-based
licensing plans okay and what that is if
I just sort of give one paragraph
overview um I I work with the new
teacher uh the superintendent and the
the CT director principal and we develop
a three-year plan for them to two sets
of Education two pieces one is what Rick
said a second ago pedagogy which is
generally curriculum instruction
assessment and uh access special ed
those four general areas um and then
they have to develop and those are
generally done through acquired
coursework um and then they have to
develop the knowledge the nuances of
Career and Technical education which is
done through mentoring coaching
networking but not formal classes so
they have a three-year window to
complete that um and uh I I think what's
important is the beauty of this model is
they do start on day one they're not
they're not they don't have to wait four
years to get a degree but on day one and
day week week one and month one and
month two it's a lot as you can imagine
so you're balancing pedagog learning the
pedagogical techniques with managing a
classroom which you know up till now
they may have been in the in working in
a hospital as a nurse they may have been
auto technician maybe a graphic designer
working at their computer all day and
now you're working your computer all day
with 25 students standing next to you
okay a little different thanks yep see
did I see a hand down the go ahead
represent thank you Mr chair
um this is a related question so you've
partly answered it but could you tell us
more
about that process of helping a trades
person or whatever discipline they're
skilled in also become a capable
educator and do they end up with an
education credential yeah so um the the
structural answer is um you you get
something called a statement of
Eligibility which demonstrates your
content knowledge basic skills knowledge
and your criminal background check that
makes you eligible to get hired you get
hired in the first 60 days we build to
plan and then you become an intern and
that's a three-year window to be an
intern and then you earn at the end of
those three years something called a
beginning educator certificate which is
98% of a regular a teacher certificate
and then there's three more years after
that you get what's called an
experienced educator and then you're
like the full poor the only difference
between experienced and a beginner is
they can't Mentor somebody in that year
four to
six so so that's the that's the concrete
part of it the I think you're asking
also on the cultural side of it too I
wasn't quite yeah so cultural side is
very complex uh as you can imagine um so
I'm going to I'm going to reference my
time in conquered um we we I'm telling
you this as an alory as a story less as
an answer I saw the absolute need to
have common structures in pedagogi in
the whole Center so that whether you the
cosmetology teacher the health science
teacher the computer science teacher we
need common structures around
particularly assessment for example
because if you don't have that common
structure these folks take this job and
their only favor referen is their own
high school experience and then you're
you're in trouble at that point you're
in deep trouble um so these folks need
Services uh locally in their school they
need services from regular Ed teachers I
I I I'm writing an article right now
where we had a real master biology
teacher uh at Conger high and I had her
Mentor a new auto teacher who you know
was brand new out but he was a bright
guy and he always says to me that was
the greatest thing that ever happened to
me being mentored by that biology
teacher who was you know practically a
PhD and she said the same thing uh but
it's really hard that's the that's the
spirit of what I'm answering you on
there's resources in the state there's
resources locally there's resources in
the professional association there's
resources from Jeff uh from the from the
from the Department of the state it
needs more it needs more attention
because it's it's it's a really really
hard prompt but the beauty of it is is
you get those folks in and they're
teaching these classes as you can
imagine students love it but they have
to be able to maintain their ability to
be
thank you very helpful
explanation could you inform us about
the adequacy or lack thereof of people
to be mentors and in in the context that
you just described yeah um um and is
there compensation for that additional
work it's good that's a good question so
first um the the state of New Hampshire
uh and sponsored by the Bureau of Crea
development um has a cluster model so
when I become the new um Plumbing
teacher or the new graphic design
teacher um I join a group of my peers in
the state via an online entity and so
that's a very powerful mentoring model
then there's local mentoring models that
depend on the district to some degree uh
for example when conquered uh part of
the collective buying agreement mandated
mentors you had to you know you you had
to have a mentor uh and mentors come in
two Frameworks one is I'm going to meor
you how to enter grades in your grade
book you know very sort of survival kind
of stuff and then there's really true
pedagogical mentoring that are going to
bring you through how to how to do all
those things and I think it's erratic I
mean that's the best answer I can give
you that's very local based um on a
state level um that cluster piece is the
answer um there's also a Statewide
conference in August people get together
but what we know is mentoring is
essential but I think when you're
nodding your head earlier
when you're you don't have a luxury of
being at UNH for 3 years starting to be
a teacher uh September 1 all of a sudden
you're in the thick and we've got to
figure out ways to reach these folks and
it's constantly
evolving yeah I spend a lot of time in
that space it's I think it's the most
critical we can talk about everything we
want in this room this is the most we
we'll get them into the job but if we
don't offer them tremendous amount of
support and training um as evidenced by
Rick's story of the money whatever
Midwest money they'll leave you know uh
and we got to find a way where they feel
fellow thank you um I have I have a
concern about the requirement B that
they need a current industry recognized
credential for one of our most needed uh
skill set and that's people who can work
on building houses because I know that
the carpentry Union has a a training
program but I live up by Plymouth and
I've never run into anybody that works
on houses that has any kind of
credential yeah so I I I feel like I can
give you a good answer to that so you
are correct that and when Rick was
talking about the professional standard
the first thing came to my mind was
construction trades it's it's all over
the place to some degree unless you're
in a union unions are very structured in
terms of what you get but there there's
a very simple cocation that the state
accepts and I think that's part of it is
OSHA um and OSHA is applicable to
everything you do in construction um and
it's a very manageable one to get so
let's just say you're a trades person
you're a mason or electrician you've
done 15 years in the field obviously if
you're a master electrician or Master
Plumber you have a c certificate but the
better example be a Mason um or someone
who does some specialty like flooring or
whatever else or carpentry where there
is no lure they would say okay I can
demonstrate to you I've done 10 years in
the field so they they they can show
customers and then they get the oosha
which is very manageable and then they
can get hired so I think the system
respects that we're not going to have
you do a makeup one like a fake one I
think that's a spirit of my
response one followup then represent bur
I'm thinking of like the the people who
um do the framing of the house and that
kind of thing do OA would definitely
apply okay without a doubt OSHA is a Val
M fact a lot of times you can't get a
job in the field without your 10 hour
oosha card like building codes yeah well
building codes would be more extreme
example but it may not be a you got to
realiz like you've been in the field 15
years you don't have a certificate you
need to get you you you know that you
know woodworking you know framing you
know Ro we just need to get you a
certificate and OSHA is generally a very
reasonable one and most folks do it and
they don't and they they they're they're
fine with it it makes sense a lot of
them have it already but if they don't
get it it's very easy to get
representative
Burton uh thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for your taking my question I
had the experience of running a
community college a couple years ago
with the traditional fashion and it was
very hard to find instructors because
they can make a lot more money working
in their field and I I take it and I had
diesel carpentry air conditioning
electricians trying to find instructors
is hard so I think one of the impetus
for this bill is to broaden your ability
to find people to to be instructors in
these field is that is that true do you
have a shortage of yeah without a doubt
right now there's a shortage uh it of
particularly trades people that's what
we're referring to uh to leave their
trades but what is unique is that there
are people at a certain age who are sort
of ready to leave the trades um their
knees are saying uh the wallet the
wallet likes the job but the knees do
not like the job um and so you've got to
sort of find people ready transition and
then I think the spirit of your comment
represent Burton is if they're ready to
transition we've got to have a nice
runway for them to do it that has that
does is not filled with friction just a
quick
follow I I was lucky because I was my
Camp was right in the middle of
darling's Volvo Ford everything my
question is
um do these vehic can work part-time too
or these you have to get the credentials
on
people teaching part-time as well as
full-time so could they have a job at a
dealership and still be instructing in
the auto program for example they could
um it's hard but yes they could I I
think what I want to mix up is the the
DAT the language of the bill says you
need have had full-time experience so
that's before but once you enter the
world could you do a hybrid yes it's
extremely difficult and I think
generally is not that productive because
you teaching
teaching is not 9
to5 as you know thank you all right well
we're out of time thank you very much
Sor I spoke too long there no it's very
useful and so I'll close the public
now okay we're on HP
484 this is relative to reallocation of
or repurposing of Career Technical
education classroom Space by local
school
districts uh 44 who is the Prime sponsor
it's represent
Daniels there is Gary
welcome J I keep calling you
things well Welcome to our committee um
we're ready well thank you thank you Mr
chairman uh good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Gary Daniels I'm the state
representative from Hillsboro District
43 representing the town of
Milford uh under current law RSA 188
e32 states that once a district has
accepted funds for the from the state
for the purpose of building space for a
Career and Technical education class or
CTE that space must be used by the
Career and Technical education center
exclusively the option of repurposing
the space is I understand it would
require that the school district buy
back from the state uh the space uh that
it that it the state had given it before
through the funding uh while I
understand the purpose of this policy in
in the short term I believe that the
policy could limit the opportunity for
students in the long term if the
district offered a CTE class in for
instance microbiology or biotech in the
interest of the students in this class
expanded Beyond the capacity of the
class any District wishing to build
additional space and vacate the current
space would need to reimburse the state
for the cost of the state the co the
cost of the space being vacated in other
words if you had 10,000 square foot of
classroom space for CTE and you wish to
expand that class to 20,000 Square F
feet to offer more opportunity for
students the choices now seem to be to
reimburse the state or to raise that is
to tear down the classroom so that the
larger classroom can be built in some
cases this may result in tearing down
the newest part of a school at an
additional and unnecessary cost to the
school
district House Bill 484 simply adds this
conditional language to RSA 188 E3 after
the word
exclusively provided that if space
within the facility has been used by the
Career and Technical education center
exclusively for at least 20 years such
space may be repurposed by the district
at no cost if the space is being vacated
to enable expansion of the Career and
Technical education program that
occupies the space if the space being V
vacated has been used for TW at least 20
years and the expansion is being done to
offer more opportunities students I feel
that the state the school districts and
the students all win the State wins by
helping to create a a CTE class that
over 20 years has shown to be successful
and in it's growing the school district
wins by saving money the taxpayers win
by saving money because they don't have
to tear down part of the building and
they can save that expense in the
expansion and the students win because
the there's more
opportunity uh for them in their
learning uh I would before I close I
would like to just give one one example
and this is kind of what prompted uh
this bill in Milford we had a CTE
expansion of Warren article last
year uh that Warren article failed and
the school district did a survey
subsequent to that to try to get an idea
of why it failed
the most common opposition to this came
in it's too much money you need to kind
cut the cost down uh second there were
other things in there but why are we
tearing down the newest part of the
school so that we can expand it was in
there
so if we're able to repurpose this space
I think it allows those that do the
designing to uh say that money that it
would cost to raise it and rebuild it in
this in this case here I mean the we've
got a current proposal that was coming
in it has since Been Changed by the
school board but they were in the
expansion proposal for this year they
were going to tear down two chemistry
labs to rebuild them in in the new CTE
expansion um I think there's a way that
we can save money in in there and so
that's what this bill uh hopes to do uh
through legisl research it was DET uh I
did find out that there is no standard
operating procedure for for what to do
with the vacated CTE space but that one
is needed and my hope is that this might
be the the the springboard to to get
something like that done and with that
Mr chairman I conclude my testimony and
be happy to take questions thank you
very much represent we learn something
every day I just learned a lot about
committee yeah yes representative Damon
then representative
P thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my
question I think I need a little
clarification
um so if I understand this proposal
correctly the space being vacated still
needs to be used for CTE or it doesn't
still need to be used for CTE under the
law it would have to be used exclusively
for CTE but in your proposed legislation
I'm I'm I'm I'm saying that if has been
used for 20 years then it has run its
course and if that uh space needs to be
used for general education another CTE
program um storage
space i i purposely left it open to be
just
it would appear please tell me if I'm
correct about this that this does not
address the situation where a district
might be interested in using CTE space
for non CTE purposes and they're not
expansion and under the current law you
could not do
that and this doesn't change that no
this this with the exception
if if you've used it for 20 years it
does change so in other words if you had
CTE space that uh you had used for 18
years and you wanted to repurpose that
for something else but again I've got
two conditions in here that have to be
met number one that it h that it has to
have been used for 20 years number two
that that it is being vacated because
you are expanding that
class and in those with those two
conditions you may take that old space
and repurpose
it thank
you representa fellow um yes I I
understand what you're doing and I think
it's a great idea the part that I don't
understand is where does it say in
statute that if we didn't put your
amendment in that they would have to pay
back the
money yeah as I as I the way I phrased
it was it is my understanding that's
what I have been told because uh we we
brought I'm on the school budget
committee and I I brought up this
question if uh we could repurpose it and
I was told that uh the the district
would have to buy the space back from
the
state yeah we don't have
let me try to give you a little
background in another area where the
20-year deal is
applicable if you receive School
building aid for a new renovation
project which meets the guidelines other
words it's going to cost more than 25%
of a new building so you want to
renovate the old and if you do that and
you accept let's say the $3.5 million to
do this and then after 10 years you
close this building
down then you as a district are still
within that 20year window you owe back
to the state the amount of the grant you
received to construct that building or
renovate that building now there is a
another provision where if in fact
something occurs like the building burns
down or something the commissioner of
education is allowed to do a waiver
process of that for various exceptions
that he or she may discern that might be
more applicable so I I I'm just trying
to figure where you came up with 20
years and I started thinking maybe the
20 years is already used in that other
other area yeah I think I C came up with
the 20 years after a talk with
commissioner Adel blue there you go yeah
and and his his comment was if if you've
run the program for 20 years it seems
though it's run its course yeah further
further questions from the committee do
we have any other cards other than uh
represent Daniels my intent was to get
you back on
schedule you're doing just that I don't
think we are off were we
no we've been uh really okay today does
the department have anything to add to
that Jeff or are you
good okay so with that not having any
more pink cards we're going to close
this hearing thank you very much
representative Daniels thank you Mr
welcome back to the house thank you and
I do have my written testimony I will
1130 so we have 15 minutes if you you
need to take a break and walk down the
time I wonder this afternoon uh repon
luno if you're going to able to keep it
as short as some as these what's that
with your bill you're doing this
afternoon what am I
fre
e
and meals for pupils in kindergarten and
we have represent Keith aan here right
now and there you are over
there Welcome to our
committee what you saying over this is
his test oh okay I'm sorry I didn't see
it
good morning or good morning almost the
end of the morning yeah education
funding committee chairman lad and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Keith Ammon I represent
Hillsboro District 42 and that's New
Boston Mount Vernon and line
bro so the testimony that I ser
circulated here it comes from the chair
of our new Boston School Board his name
is Bill
Schmidt um and the gist of what we're
trying to do with this with this bill is
eliminate a
mandate so New Boston we have a central
school it's a it's K through
six and we still have half day
kindergarten so what we're finding or
what what the school board in town is
finding is that mandates on busing and
lunches uh meal service are overly
restrictive for our situation and so
this testimony here from Cher Schmidt
I'll just I won't read the whole thing
because you have it in front of you but
we
have we currently have second paragraph
we currently have halfday kindergarten
program and have not implemented a full
day program due to space and cost
constraints this program has worked out
well for our students so he goes on to
talk about how it's been part of the
culture in town that parents uh in the
school cooperate on making sure the half
day students end up where they're
supposed to be after the the half day is
over so and that has worked out well for
our town um the fourth paragraph when it
comes to meals we already have a short
period of time when these children are
at school the meal requirement not only
adds unnecessary cost but takes away
from instruction time so I thought that
was a Salient
point and uh he concludes by asking the
committee to recommend ought to pass on
this legislation so with that you guys
are the experts on on education funding
but that's the intent of what we're
trying to do is eliminate mandates that
apply more to full day kindergarten and
that are a little awkward for our school
district thank you very much uh are
there questions from the
committee for the representative
representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question are there do all students are
in the same half of the day or is there
two groups one that's the morning and
one that's the afternoon that's a good
question I don't I don't know the answer
to that I I believe it's one uh it's
half the day I could reach back out to
to Bill Schmidt his phone number is on
the back somehow it printed on the very
back so all of his contact inform thank
you
further
questions yeah representative Damon um
this isn't a question it actually says
in the first paragraph morning or AM or
PM session assume that there's two all
committee I don't see any hands all
right great thank you very much so
Bill's also there there hand we have a
question okay
thank you for taking my
question so I'm
curious um in the second paragraph where
he speaks about the details of it
mandated to provide midday
Transportation um talking about it
taking over an hour so is this a very
geographically widespread
District I mean if you've been to New
Boston it's a have not not it's not a
big town but it's not a Tiny Town either
either so we have a lot of Hills and
Valleys and windy roads in town that can
add some time to trips and
transportation
so okay further questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you very
much all right thank you are there any
other pink cards for this particular
Laura
milikin
welcome new Hunger New Hampshire hunger
good morning chairman lad and and
honorable members of the committee my
name is Laura milikin I'm the executive
director of New Hampshire hunger
Solutions we appreciate the opportunity
to testify today in opposition to uh HB
319 we're a Statewide nonpartisan
nonprofit organization that Advocates to
end food insecurity improve Equitable
access to nutritious food and address
hunger root causes for all New Hampshire
residents we all agree that children
should have an equal opportunity at
success in school and in life we agree
that children need a classroom a teacher
books curriculum but access to meals is
even more important because children
cannot learn when they're
hungry this bill comes at a time that we
know that many families are struggling
to make ends meet and food insecurity
has been increasing the Census Data tell
us that currently over a third of
households with children are reporting
that they have sufficient food School
meals are essential to providing
children with the nutrition they need to
succeed in school many Studies have
found that children who eat uh School
meals have better nutrition better
physical and mental health and I've
provided you with the research about
that kindergarten is fundamental to the
rest of a child's academic
career this bill would take away
nutritious meals from some of our
youngest students threatening their
ability to focus and learn please vote
in expediate to legislate on HB 319
because every child deserves an equal
opportunity to
succeed thank you thank you very much
are there questions from our
committee yes representa luno thanks
thanks very much Mr chair and thank you
very much M Milligan for joining us
again um you know as as the the the bill
applies to both transportation and um
and food nutrition programs and meals so
and and seems to uh eliminate the
requirement to provide either to um to
students who attend half day uh
kindergarten programs is that is that
your read on that is my read yeah yeah
thanks thanks and and um and so so in in
a situation where where a student
student is um and we're talking about
what 5year
olds you know um attending a halfday
kindergarten program what could their if
they were attending a halfday morning
program or a halfday afternoon program
what would their day look like or what
could their day look like from the time
they leave home
um get to school and then get back
home you know in terms of um
actually having a
meal so you know it of course varies by
School District um but uh I'm really
saying like in the worst case if you're
if you're not providing Transportation
or meals in the worst case they would be
in half toe kindergarten in the morning
leave school without breakfast get uh if
this bill pass they could get to school
and have no breakfast it would be very
difficult for such a child to to
concentrate they would likely I mean
5-year-olds they would likely act out
because they're hungry um you know it is
not uh it's not a benefit to school
districts to not feed kids um and um you
know I mean without transportation I
don't I don't know how they get to
school I uh you know I spent many years
working in early childhood policy and I
certainly understand that um children
who aren't able to get uh the Early
Education
um that they need are not ready for
school when they come they are at a
significant disadvantage um and so we
just we just don't want to disident into
our kids in any way um and so we need to
to feed them and transport them thank
yes um my question is were you are you
talking about providing them with a
breakfast meal before they begin their
class or are you talking about providing
them with like a bag lunch to take with
them
um what what exactly
um because I understand what you're
saying about uh the young children
without having breakfast I've been there
so I understand what that means and is
that what you're talking about providing
something before they begin
school so the bill doesn't address which
meal um uh the Bill addresses uh the
fact that um schools are currently
required to offer a meal to students um
and so I would certainly I would
certainly like it if um schools offered
breakfast and lunch um I think that um
you know whether it's uh in a a bag or
in um in the cafeteria um it doesn't
matter as long as it you know meets
nutritional requirements I you know
every children child deserves to have a
nutritious meal um if they're expected
to be able to function in
school thank you very much are there
further questions yes representa
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
being here and helping us with
this there is a statement in the written
it wasn't presented fully testimony from
the chair of the school board who
requested this um proposed legislation
that um the meal requirement would not
only add unnecessary cost but it takes
away from instruction
time I'm interested in your perspective
on the validity of that statement it
seems to me there are a number of ways
that males can be provided that do not
take away from instruction time thank
you for the question I I think that um
what I what I said before and what I
what I believe the research shows is
that children have a much better chance
of success when they've eaten breakfast
um that children can't learn like all of
us when we're hungry we have difficulty
focusing and and a 5-year-old has a much
harder time um and so we want to make
sure that they have the tools they need
to be able to succeed in school um and I
think that um the the instructional time
you know I mean children at that age act
out when they are hungry um so I think
that the idea that you would be saving
instructional time um is is uh not is a
fallacy I just don't think that's real
much one one more question that's it I
have other question you know nutrition
is interesting to
me
um so am I correct that it would be
possible for a district with a half day
kindergarten program where children are
certainly having a snack of some sort
during the morning whether parent or
District
provided can the school create a
situation where they make that snack
qualify as a meal per the federal meal
standards uh I don't know the answer to
that I'm sorry to say I can get back to
you on that that's a question that you
might want to ask the Department of
Education um or or you know or folks who
were a little more familiar with the ins
and outs of the of the USDA requirements
than I am okay thank you thank you um so
what I'd like to do now if we do have
the Department of Education here and I
thank you very much for your testimony
let's switch it to the doe right now and
I have one question then I'm going to
open it up to the representatives
here how many halfday kindergarten
programs do we have in the state and
that the second part of that question is
when I was in the a school principal in
the other state I came from which was
Alaska we'd have the kids in the half
day program come in because our school
wasn't large enough to contain all the
students so we split this particular
group up one group would come in the
morning stay through lunch the other
group would come in prior to lunch and
come to the end of the day and and after
the first group's done lunch then they
went home but we provided that social
experience for both groups to get to
know each other at that lunch time and
they both receive the meal and they
receive Transportation on the buses uh
do we have any programs operating like
that in the state that have these half
day programs due to maybe space
availability in the building well so
white division director for learner
Support Department of Education um every
school in their Logistics on how they're
serving meals is a little bit different
I think the um component I wanted to
speak to is that the the US Department
of
Agriculture um national school lunch
program and the school breakfast program
requires a meal to be offered to every
student regardless of whether they're
full-time or part-time in order to
participate in that
program so if it's a federal
requirement that that I think pretty
much sums it up so in followup to that
though if if they require that every
student had this every student should be
offered offered meal okay offered so
changing it and that's for the all all
students that attend that school
regardless of their grade level correct
so if you have grades let's say one
through
six getting involved in this program but
the kids in grade K aren't getting that
is that in violation of what you just
said
that is in violation okay and when we
find schools that are conducting that we
make sure that they offer a meal to
those
students any other questions for Melissa
white
yes I'm sorry because I might have
missed something did you say that these
are for the schools that are accepting
the federal money for the federal school
program if the school is participating
in the national school lunch program or
the school breakfast program so followup
mhm so is it possible that we have
schools that are not participating in
that program like such as the charter
school
right thank you and we have um 440
schools throughout the state that are
programs oh I don't have that one off
the top of my list
here I can get that to you
though there are a few I can remember
representative B speaking to his
community was one which they had their
own meal
program yeah so
that if this was to be
passed then you really couldn't
require the school to be serving meals
at the reduced C rate reduced cost rate
and meeting the federal income
eligibility guidelines because you
wouldn't be able to access the USDA
programs so
hey yes represent repres thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
so the letter we have from New Boston
says they have obtained a waiver for
this uh meal requirement is that from
your department from the federal
government from um so that would be from
our department but that's a waiver to
compliance all right maybe may I follow
yeah that they they were found to not
offered that program and so if you're
operating the national school lunch
program or the school breakfast program
you have to make a meal available so if
it's found that a school is not making
that meal available they can have a
temporary waiver but then they have to
come into compliance with that
requirement and changing the state law
is not going to change the federal
law thank you wow look they're scooting
around repesent fellows yes thank you
you um it's my understanding that
waivers have been issued to schools and
there are also my understanding that
this apply does this apply to Charter
Schools if the charter school is
operating the national school lunch
program or the school breakfast program
then yes are but if they are not then no
are are they
not required to no school is required to
operate those programs but they have if
they want want to partake in the um meal
program and be able to offer free meals
and reduceed price meals then
yes it's a school's choice though
schools can choose not to operate those
programs
okay so and follow quickly on on that is
there
a criteria or conditions which the
federal government have that a waiver to
the program be can be given
yes is there where can I find the
information I can send that to the
committee so it stipulates here's your
waivers possible areas you can waiver
for and it really gives us the
opportunity to then provide technical
assistance our department our uh
nutrition program to then help them
Implement whatever changes or systems
they might need in order to be able to
provide and to come into
compliance thank you yes so the waiver
is temporary it's not like you're going
to have forever and ever correct okay
representa Fells you got your second
question ready yes I'm wondering if you
could give us a list of the waivers that
have been granted for the last 5 years
because I do believe that there are
schools who repeatedly are receiving
waivers okay yes further questions from
the committee yes
representative reading the testimony
from New Boston it seems like the the
weight of this mandate is the 75,000 in
transportation is it possible that the
food won't cost near that much the food
that's being offered and mandated by the
feds is that can we can we divorce the
if they're offering a meal to meet the
requirements all of those students that
are um at a reduced
cost there's going to be the feds you
know covering a component of that cost
plus then there's a cost to the student
then for the students that are free
that's meal is covered if you're
offering a meal to the rest of those
students they're paying that cost or
depending on whatever that school's
policy is for charging for meals so for
those children that don't qualify for
the free and reduced price lunches if
you're offering a meal to them they
meal can I follow yes go ahead but none
of that enters into the cost of the
transportation they really are in
reality divorced thank you food yeah
food and nutrition program completely
separate from Transportation
costs yes represent
Damon so what is the length of time for
a temporary waiver in this case I'm not
sure so I would have to get that
information and give more information on
the waiver process thank you appreciate
I can look this information I probably
find it what's the population of this
school in New Boston do you have any
idea do they have several sessions of
kindergarten that I don't know off the
top of my head either Becky maybe you
have
the so my question would be that where
there's a transportation cost a bus has
to take the morning kids home or maybe
they're not doing that or or bring them
to school they're not doing that
either they do in the morning when the
buses are going by the
evening mid okay I so morning class see
usually when you have two the bus brings
in and takes the others
thank you very much appreciate it any
other folks that have pink cards or
desire to give us some input on this
one not seeing it so we're going to
close this hearing and the next hearing
12:45
only well it this is an EFA bill you
never know what's going to go on I want
to call I just got to call Kate Baker
make sure Kate's here or Matt Southerton
here in case there's questions because I
don't get in that
Arena know Jim Jim's sick today hope
wedding we're just hearing we're not
taking
any
e
we're ready to go ahead and start on the
hearing at this
time uh what we we have in front of us
is one bill this afternoon it's HB
549 it's relative to the use of
Education Freedom account funds in
religious schools and institutions of
higher
education I I'd like to welcome
representative Tim Horgan to present uh
the bill as he is the prime sponsor
thank you very much before I sit down
I'll uh I've got two two uh two pieces
of written material my testimony and
then an article from the conquer monitor
but so we I've already passed it down to
that side of the table but I'll just
pass it down the first person on the
other side and make sure everybody gets
one okay and they they can pass it
around
yeah I was I was I was expecting a
bigger crowd because this is a uh
controversial issue but um I guess
everybody came to the previous hearing
so right I'm T represent Timothy Horan
from straford County district 6 which is
the town of Durham um also uh one of my
fellow straford County District 10 um
members is a member of this committee so
I see he's here so so
um so what this does pretty simply well
it does a couple of other things but the
main thing it does it forbids using
money from the so-called education
Freedom account to pay for Religious
Education then that program as uh
everybody all of you know is sometimes
also called the school voucher program
but by either name I believe is the
program violates several articles of the
State Constitution especially part first
article six um and uh I don't know do
you want me to read the whole thing or
it's you've got you've got the text it
be wise if you don't read it all because
uh we've got it here we can read it yeah
okay anyway by either name the program
authorized by RSA 94f doesn't merely
allow state tax taxpayer funds to be
used to support religious education that
actively encourages it um the same could
be said about the education tax credit
program established by RSA um
77g um this bill um this bill makes no
changes to that program it's smaller
more constrained and it's a voluntary
tax credit which doesn't take money
directly from the general or education
funds
and um as and this is something you all
know but uh I'll state it for the record
anyway both the EFA and Etc programs are
ministered to the children's scholarship
fund New Hampshire which is its name
notwithstanding Incorporated in New York
City rather than New Hampshire it does
however have an office in conquer um out
in Lowden Road interestingly on the uh
Campus of a local church I'm not sure
whether it's in the basement but
somewhere in the property of the church
and I was just wondering about csfs NH
when it arrived here in Grand stage
several years ago since it was and still
is a small organization administering a
very complicated entitlement program on
a Cost Plus basis um I'm still dubious
today especially the much larger much
more ambitious EFA program has been
added on top of the old Etc program and
it could become even bigger than it is
now depending what action is taken you
know on other legislation so it its main
mission is uh quite openly to support
religious education which is fine you
can look at their own public relations
material it states very explicitly that
they favor spending public money on
religious education so I'm certainly I
am not opposed to religious education
but using taxpayer dollar support um
such education is is a blatant violation
of part first article six and it's um
it's questionable under the federal
Federal Constitution too so using
taxpayer do for that purposes is also
bad policy um to name to name just for
many reasons name just one reason the
EFA program gives the government the
power to reward some religions which it
approves of approves of while punishing
others it disapproves of and um and I
was in the legislature 2012 as you were
Mr chair when Etc program was created as
well as 2021 when the EFA was created
and the scholarship organization written
both programs and I believe this is
pretty openly stated at the time with
the expectation that it' be exempt from
many of the state and federal
regulations which an agency such as the
state department of education is
required to obey so I was
um and uh I was not in the legislation
1995 when the Charter Public School
program is established with the laws uh
company that program are pretty much the
same over the last three decades and the
chared school program explicitly
excluded religious education which was
um I think the right thing to do for
constitutional practical and financial
reasons So speaking of finances the EA's
recent growth has been uh i prepar to
describe it as out of control um HB 549
in my opinion reduced the cost of the
fir by a huge amount um certainly more
than half and U and I know the fiscal
note just says it's indeterminable um I
and it's uh incomplete the but LBA uh
the LBA um asked asked for a fiscal note
worksheet um from the Department of
Education they and they've not filled it
out as far as I I checked I checked on
the bill docket the most recent version
of the bill do still not have the
revised fiscal note so or the fiscal not
if there FIS was revised um it was it's
uh hard to figure out where to find it
so um and they
also they they did make a comment that
they didn't know like uh to what extent
EFA programs participants would remain
in the program and just repurpose their
available funding to comply with the
changes in the bill so I would think
probably
uh I think I think probably many of them
many of them would but anyway
so and um we had this bill last year and
I analyzed the available data which is a
couple years out of date um there's an
article in December by the conquer
Monitor jery margalus and that showed
the vouch which um I'll say first of all
his analysis was pretty similar to what
I did in uh two years ago and I had a
similar bill it's um and I double
checked it myself and um he you know I
think he basically got everything right
so
um anyway so his his article and I I
sent around a copy the article it says
there's a the program directly
subsidizes 115 private schools 60 of
which are religious schools uh 24 of the
20 20 25 schools receiving those fund as
of the 2023 Academic Year which for some
reason the numbers for 2324 aren't
available are explicitly religious
including the top 10 and uh in 22 and 23
private schools received 6.5 million
religious schools got um 1 5.6 million
and secular schools got only uh 900 well
a little over 900,000 so that's uh 86
86% went to religious schools 14% went
to secular schools even though Private
School enrollment is about equally
divided between private and uh religious
and secular schools and uh and that's
out of the whole program which is 10.4
million so the uh families who are
paying for for other expenses uh some of
which are related to Religious Education
they only spend uh 3.9 million and
uh those figures are all much higher in
in in in this Academic Year and also for
the previous one but they've not really
released those detailed numbers so I
would assume the I assume the
percentages are
probably um pretty much the same from
from year to year and I think that
certainly is a certain as a topic that
might be approprate appropriate for a
work session if you want to have one and
um Andor you can leave that I assume
this bill if if passed would go to
finance as a second committee do you
know that Mr chair or um okay I I don't
know so um as I said I I think the the
article I passed around that's uh that's
that's accurate that's about about the
same as what I would have come up if I
went through the same available data on
my own and um that 3.9 million the other
dollars well two years ago 3.9 million
um I think a lot of percentage of those
bucks are also being spent on other
forms of religious education so that's
the main main most controversial thing
although it's less controversial than I
thought because nobody's here
but um although the committee is mostly
here so that's good there um there's two
other issues which are not directly
related to the issue of funding
religious education section one
stipulates the higher education
institutions receiving EFA funds would
have to be accredited and um
I when I L at the 2223 numbers I
couldn't actually find any non-
accredited higher education institutions
but uh if there are any they're no
longer eligible for the
program and also section three takes out
special legal protections which are
granted to EFA recipients and to the
scholarship organization itself um
henceforth if this bill passes when you
use the EFA program to violate the law
or to violate anyone else's Constitution
or common law rights you could be held
liable just like anyone else who misuses
the taxpayers money so I've covered so
that's my written testimony which all of
you have probably read by now and I also
say as also reiterate again um this is
already one of the larger entitlement
programs in the state if the bill we
heard two weeks ago or or seem like or
whenever that was but re fairly recently
which I testified on if that passes that
would probably become the second largest
entitlement program in the whole state
aside from uh aside from snap for food
stamps and food stamps has a very robust
administrative structure around it
there's a both
Department of Human Health and Human
Services the Federal Department of
Agriculture like have a lot of people
overseeing it they've got a you know got
very detailed rules um this this program
um it's
getting the way it's structured gives
very the doe very little power over or
any other state agency and then the doe
in my opinion has not necessarily been
very aggressive and even using what
power we power it has and there's um
there's also the issue of uh it's can't
really it's hard to audit and what
there's a very limited audit and that
found an alarmingly high percentage of
incorrect you know incorrect
transactions and I'm not I'm not
integrating the Integrity of the
children's scholarship fund New
Hampshire but it's a it's a small
organization it's very it's um not
really there very few people who
experience in compliance like in
administering entitlement programs so
it's primarily it's focuses on on on
other issues so turning a large program
like that over to an organization like
that is fairly risky and I assume if the
I'm going to guess not that Crystal Ball
but uh if this program continues in the
future probably there will be more
administrative uh oversight of it just
because there's a there's a lot of money
there's a lot of ways to abute anytime
the government hands out money as it
doing here there's lots of ways to abuse
it and uh people will find them so
that's my uh that's my testimony here
and I'm happy to take any questions
thank you very much are there any
questions from the
committee representative fellows
thank you um this is enlightening um I'm
looking at the the monitor article and
with the list of the religious schools
where the funding goes and then I also
see that somebody connected with the
voucher program says that kids attending
those
schools um they're not necessarily
looking for the religious part of the of
the um curriculum but they looking for
more traditional
experiences and then the other day when
we heard testimony on the voucher Bill
we heard about um schools that were more
in line with their family values um do
you have any thoughts on what that well
I
think if you go to if you go to a
religious religious school um you're you
know you're going to learn about the the
religion I myself spent the last two
years of my high school career at a uh
the Northville M Herman school which is
uh in Massachusetts although it's right
on the state line but it's still in that
other state and uh but um you know they
they had students of of like all faith
my parents were not uh they're brought
up brought of as my father's a Roman
Catholic and my mother's Episcopalian
they're not particularly religious
people but they sent me there and I you
know I I absorbed a lot of it although
it still turned out the way I did so
that I think anytime you send some to
Religious Education regards what the
parents motivation is the kids children
are going to uh learn what they're being
children going to learn learn what
they're being taught um and and uh the
AL like the family values um I mean
guess uh I mean I think our Public
Schools do respect Family Values
everybody's a different opinion about
family values is and also so sometimes a
lot of the um comments I heard in
support of like expanding the program we
were and maybe that's it's a good thing
May it's a bad thing we're definitely
many cases uh a subsidizing sort of
lifestyle decisions that families make
about how they're going to live which
often involves uh one parent or
sometimes both um with especially when
your homeschooling sometimes involes one
parent kind of withdrawing from uh the
conventional Workforce and uh you know
devoting their devoted time to
homeschooling the kids which is fine and
actually this pill doesn't really
directly affect homeschoolers so but um
yeah I mean everybody you know every
family every family has values
regardless of what type of school
they're going to they're going the
children are going to absorb it and even
even if it's a very you know even if
you're very liberal family you'll learn
about traditional stuff you very
traditional family you know they'll
learn about stuff outside the family so
um I I I feel like ass with the state
budget crisis we should be very careful
about what we're subsidizing or State
dollars in some cases I think we're
subsidizing uh subsidizing Act ities
that may not need the subsidy um
and R SES do you have a question yeah um
first first a question to you if you
don't mind um and that is do you have
any other pink cards or is anybody else
testifying no I I don't have any other
pink cards up here okay
so I'll ask a couple of questions the
one witness we have um but um I really
think it's important this is an
important issue that we at least hear
from the children's scholarship fund and
also uh from the uh uh the what is it
LBA yeah uh uh regarding the audit and
uh also that we hear from the Department
of Education on uh how on the logistics
the actual way in which these vouchers
are processed um and what role the uh
Department plays in the processing and
what role the uh and approval I should
say and uh what role the scholarship
fund plays and what role the parents
play you know getting getting all the
dimensions of this out on the table so
that we can make a reasonable judgment
on this proposal um so I hope we will I
will just say I I hope we will have uh a
uh opportunity to work on this in a in a
session after we finish this hearing um
which is uh limited by the number of
people we have before us uh so well let
me quickly respond to that we had a
hearing for 115 which started at 1:00 we
completed around 6 o' in the afternoon
so we had a 5H hour
hearing and the balance of cards that
came in not those which were done
through the portal but the cards came in
was pretty even
and what we we heard from one side is
the is the position that uh I believe
represent Horgan is coming from and then
the other side was
saying this bill specifically is
unconstitutional the courts have already
declared that public money can be used
for uh private education including
religious education and if we disallow
that it's
discrimination so uh there are two
diametrically opposed positions on this
um so I I think that after a 5our
conversation of hearing and hearing and
hearing you I I think it's time for us
eventually we're getting very close to
having to make a decision where we're
going to go on this bill uh in terms of
today uh I don't see anybody else here
because it's a specific Bill dealing
about these money's being used for
Religious
Education and with that I think was
pretty well identified by those that
came in saying no it's not
constitutional that we went through that
hp15 I don't think it's necessary to go
through it again
representative I but no I I don't know
how to actually well I'm just gonna say
it but we have not heard from the
children's scholarship fund about this
yet have we they weren't here the so is
that something that we should like when
we have a work session or I mean I
assume we have a work session that don't
forget this is my first year so I'm a
little
bit um I don't know lost maybe but when
we have a work
session is that the kind of thing that
we would have in the work session like
would we hear from would we be able to
question the children's scholarship fund
would we be able to question like the
DOE
about oversight and all that stuff I so
we do have an oversight committee for
this purpose the EFA oversight committee
they issued a report this last year and
well recently for the last year and they
went through and looked at all the
reports the audits the the information
regarding the how funds are being used
uh for for what types of activities
whether it be books or tutoring Etc uh
we went through and looked at the report
which identified some of the the errors
which had be made regard for example the
net gross income net income versus gross
income uh which have all been taken care
of uh so there this has been done in the
scholarship uh children's scholarship uh
uh fund
organization has testified on this this
before the Committees before um I not in
this committee no not in this committee
hb15 sorry so you mean when through
folks there so I didn't the children's
scholarship fund was here
on last week I don't think that
happened no K Baker did not test but
true folks that were
attending that that or you know the
thefa program they did
testify so you know whether we have a
work session or not I'm going to have to
decide that um um it's it's one where um
quite truthfully I know where the vote's
going on
this and I think you do
too and and when I have to prioritize
where and how we're going to be using
our time here
I I believe we have some other very
critical issues which going to have to
develop a lot of time too and so um I'm
not going to say yay or nay on on the
work session on that a lot of the
bills uh we don't do work sessions on
and so if you are desirous of gaining
some information from them you're more
than welcome to contact them to get the
information any other questions for
represent thank you Mr Mr chairman and
thank you representative for taking my
question so you made a point here um
from this conquer monitor article that a
lot of a lot of money goes to religious
schools and um is it possible that the
reason for that is that the EFA program
is limited to parents of modest means
and that the schools that are available
in the state that are accessible to
people of modest means tend to be
religious um I think there's a lot more
to it than that um which I spoke um I
didn't I wasn't I didn't speak to I
spoke to like several of uh the schools
that uh receive funds although only one
of which was a uh Roman Catholic School
which was explicitly religious was the
Roman Catholic School actually a
boarding school located in Pennsylvania
which um and but what what I heard from
officials at all three institutions is
that they try as much as POS well some
of them have explicitly need blind um
need blind uh admissions policies like I
talked to some who actually very or you
say very one of them has a very large
endowment probably bigger richer than
most colleges and three other
institutions are two other secular
institutions here in New Hampshire were
somewhat smaller but they told me they
they they work first by identifying the
students who apply who they think are
good fit for the program and of course
that's problematic to to because this
these schools
usually don't they have some special
need students but they don't you know do
the very difficult special needs cases
and actually the religious school that
was out of state explicitly said they
don't want anybody who any learning
disabilities at the program was only for
it was only for boys too but um they
they explicitly that they need a certain
type of young man for this program and
that was fine I mean that it was seemed
like a good program for a certain type
of young young man but they all they all
to lesser greater or lesser extent have
uh endowments they have other sources of
funding they um solicit um solicit
donations they basically most of them so
the way they typically operated they
find a student who's interested and then
they find a way for the family to afford
it so this is uh at the EFA at least the
way the especially at least way the
secular schools the way it works that's
one of the sources of funding so
somebody I mean they know who's a modest
means and who isn't but they they they
they find they find the family and then
they figure how the family can pay for
it and sometimes it's out of the
school's own endowment sometimes it's
out of loans you know sometimes it's if
they're lucky the family's own funds
fact you a really wealthy family they'll
try to get you for more donations on top
of tuition but it's a familiesal funds
and then the EA voucher is uh if it's
available is one of the other things
that goes into the mix so I think um
think a lot of the spending both of the
second religious schools is displacing
spending that otherwise would have come
from the the private sector you know so
that's uh and so that's why I think this
bill is I think why I think my bill is
is is uh is good policy not you know
especially with the budget crisis we're
having this year so that's U it's along
with the answer I think there's more to
it than that it's not just because uh
the um especially the Roman Catholic
parochial schools charge lower tuition
than most other private institutions
thanks forther questions yes
uh you mentioned that they don't um
receive special students is it possible
that they just don't have the budget to
receive special ed students because they
don't receive any state funding for
those special ed students um that's uh I
mean the uh well that's probably that's
probably true that might be another
topic you discuss at a work session it's
based on the adequacy funding which does
give you a little bit more funding for
the special education students but
that's uh know that's a question
probably that somebody else can answer
but you know there are there definitely
are some of these institutions who
explicitly exclude uh special needs
students and they're all and of course
they all probably best suited for you
know children of who's with supportive
families and who have like a maybe uh at
least like a good work work work ethic
and higher intelligence and the kids who
don't get admitted who have to go to
school somewhere in the public schools
uh get a higher percentage of those
students who you know have a little bit
more difficulty reaching their academic
goals than the ones that are in these
institutions
so further yes go ahead okay thank you
chairman uh thank you representative for
taking my
question you stated in your testimony
that you felt this program is wildly out
of control yeah couldn't that conversely
be construed as wildly
successful um I
it's it's successful for the families
who who benefit from them but I think
it's not not necessarily successful for
the population as a whole so and one
thing about all these education debates
too is that families generally speaking
and the children themselves like the
schools they're at so uh much as we
Grumble about education and what very
obviously very difficult process very
long and painful process going through
Elementary and secondary education but
most families you know most children and
most parents like their schools whatever
type of school it is and like their like
their teachers one thing with the debate
is the public
schools don't have as much don't have
much opportunity to come to conquer like
so if a child like say uh I to live near
the school bus stomp from my
neighborhood back it's right across the
street so those kids who get picked up
around and get at 8 8 8 8:10 a.m. and it
get dropped off you know they're they're
happy going to school you know I mean
maybe not sometimes they Grumble but
they're they're happy to be going to
school they're uh having a positive
experience while there and they're um
dropped off again having had a
productive day and um they're very cute
very beautiful and doing great things
and we don't see these we don't see
these kids just because they're in
school and you know Public Schools can't
bu students here to up here to the
second floor of the LLB to attend
education funding or education policy
committee hearings and then often times
the parents or other people affiliated
with the other forms of Education make
uh comments about our public schools
which are pass more negative than what
they should be Although our Public
Schools you know are far from perfect
and need to be improved
but thank you was it repr
names yeah I said I'd ask a couple of
questions directly to the witness rather
than to you U so I'm going to try to do
that um
representative haran do you um have
information or knowledge
of discriminatory practices that for a
public school would be illegal that uh
private school recipients of these
EFA funds um may be engaging in um I
think there I think there think there
are some um I'm not prepared to go into
like whole detail about it that's
another Poss another topic that should
be studied I mean certainly we certainly
in terms of a religious discrimination
just even though these religious schols
will admit people from other faiths
obviously that's obviously there's uh
the parents religious beliefs have to be
at least somewhat compatible with the
religious beliefs of the school um and
um so I think there's a certain amount
of that even um you know I mean they're
all run by honorable people and they
make an effort to be inclusive and uh
you know we still you know we still have
anti-discrimination laws on the books
regardless of any you know executive
orders that may have been introduced in
Washington DC but although that's not
really our problem we're in Conquer New
Hampshire we've got enough to worry
about so I think there may be problems
in that that certainly should be looked
into further question repres
B uh clarification Mr
chairman I'm a little confused earlier
you said that you seem to infer that the
3700 people who voted who weighed in
because it was competing with at a time
when they were feeling tax poor that
their opinion was less valuable than the
even number of people who attended the
hearing I I don't think you meant to do
that uh I I would hope we would respect
the people who can't get to conquered
and weigh in as equal to the people who
come to the actual hearing make their
feelings known the fact is there was a 4
to1 ratio of people opposed mainly
because I think it they see it's a uh a
conflict uh not not necessar
religious but at a time when the state
is Cash
trapped it seems to be a a a use of
funds that is out of control anyone who
has an income a high income can
participate
I I don't think you meant to do that did
you I think you're asserting a lot of
your personal opinion into this thing um
I indicated that yes we had a number of
people in the portal who signed
in but when we came to the actual
hearing
itself it went back and forth back and
forth throughout the day uh so that's
where I was coming from that there are
two sides to this
equation and uh the number of people
that came in on the portal
um there there are large large groups
out there that can send out boom and it
hits you know a couple thousand people
just like that and you can have coming
in I respect all the people that come in
a portal don't misunderstand me there
and I respect that
message um so where I am right now on
this particular
bill this particular bill is dealing
with one section of one thing that's the
use of money used for religious schools
by the EFA
program and some of the areas we're
getting into are discussions which
belong in the policy and administration
committee they're the ones which would
do oversight of the EFA program we're
looking primarily at the fiscal impacts
that this program may have on our state
Budget on on on the revenues coming in
and um that's what we're looking at and
that's what we're hearing so um I think
you've put a l a lot of inference into
that represent Burton and um you're
trying to read people's
minds I would suggest that uh you are
not reading mine properly I'm open to
everybody participating everybody coming
into a hearing we've always welcomed
people as we're welcoming represent
again today and he does a lot of work in
putting his paperwork together when he
comes in here and that's understood and
that's
appreciated but in this particular
situation right now I know where we're
going to go with this thing we went last
year when you weren't in the house it
was pretty evenly split and we came out
with numerous no recommendation votes
this year I don't see that
happening yes would you be willing to to
put another number on the amount of
money we should spend on this everything
else in the budget is going to have a
cap except this one you're going Way
Beyond this bill now put a number on it
well can you put a number on all the
issues which we're talking about can you
put a number on what we need to put on
school building 8 the governor is going
to put a number on all of those that's
the Governor's job representa B except
I'm not going to get into a discussion
with you at this meeting on that that's
way off task of this hearing are there
any other questions regarding this Bill
yes represent
Damon thank you Mr chair um I'm asking
for clarification from your remarks a
moment ago I believe you were saying
that this bill should perhaps be heard
in the other education committee did I
understand no that's not what I said
well that's why I asked for
clarification there are policy issues
associated with the EFA program which
are strictly policy issues and not money
issues this when we come to the bills
which come to this committee on efas we
are directly looking at the fiscal
impacts to our state budget that's the
mission of this committee right here the
other side of the coin where we talk
strictly policy and physical is when it
comes to Career Technical education
higher education all those other
programs have been left to the other
committee and that was one the reason
why we did it you saw the load you were
on it last year you know the load of
bills which we came in and we had
virtually no time for subcommittee work
at all we're just trying to get bills
heard exact and out and doing that with
those 235 bills over the course of that
buying was a real load that's why we
split this up so when it comes to the
policy side that's their chore on the
other side of
well you in this room we're not
here may I yes thank you I appreciate
the explanation and review for all of us
and I do appreciate that there are two
education committees as you noted last
year's workload was very
significant and that leads me
to um respectfully urge that we do have
a work session on this bill so that we
can get full financial information as
much as it's
available on the costs
of the spending through the EFA program
for religious schools or other religious
expenses I think we should have that
information I do not feel like I
received that information in the hearing
on 115 last week and it seems to me
there's a number of other folks with
questions are there any other
questions of the
person
testifying yes ref some
mire thank you Mr chairman um I'd like
to our chairman made a interesting uh
point about um the legal history of this
topic right that that that the religious
aspect has been litigated and courts
have found that what we're doing is
constitutional and that um should we try
to discriminate against
religious um schools or persons in the
way that that this bill might
do we might run a foul of of
anti-discrimination aspect so what do
you think of of um that argument well
the the Court decisions Al there have
been many Federal Court decisions
related to um government expenditures
supporting religious education but some
mostly
and most of those don't apply any the
situations those applies to are not 100%
analogous to this one and the um just on
the state level state level I think the
black the plain letter law of the
Constitution is pretty clear that this
program is a violation of the of the
State uh of the uh state constitution I
think there's Federal issues with it too
and also we um of course an alternative
alter another alternative approach you
can take uh which I would consider and
that not be a popular Amendment but I
would consider a friendly Amendment
would be just to phase out the program
Al together because I think um I think I
think it's I think it's not a good
policy on top of you know top of the
Constitutional issue I also think it's a
bad policy and one one of the choices we
have is to uh just you know get rid of
it you probably have to phase it out
over the course of at least a year
because families are depending on it in
good faith but um yeah so that's um so I
I if I if I believed that this bill was
totally unconstitutional I would not I
would not have filed it and I probably
would have also been at least chided by
the drafting attorney that this is this
is UN that this is unconstitutional but
this this similar language has been
approved by ol you know last session and
this session and there's also also even
if you don't like the religious
education part there are like the last
two sections of bill which we didn't
talk about much and those those have
Merit on their own to regardless of the
religious issue thanks any further
questions represent mhan thank you thank
you Mr chairman I I just have a question
from the article that you raised what I
see in that article from the conquer
monitor is a significant choice that
people have made it's almost a
unilateral Choice do you think it's wise
to um to deny them their constitutional
right to the free practice of their
choices
I mean I don't think I don't think
restricting or Li this program like
restricts anybody's religious choices I
mean families do have different choices
if we subsidize certain forms of
Education that will incentivize them to
choose that over others but think it's
there's still other ways they can be
able to make make that choice and um and
even with the current income
restrictions they're fairly uh fairly
liberal especially
because there's a provision that if you
put your child in there even in
kindergarten they're eligible until they
graduate from high school and usually
the family
income if if your parents are like most
parents they're like uh in the they're
in a um time of life when their earnings
potential like increases a lot every
year too so the families most cases the
family's uh income if things go the way
they should and usually be as like Much
Higher by the time that the child is is
out of there and that's actually not
addressed by this spill but that's like
a something that you could look at as uh
changing the way the eligibility is
determined but so that's long with
answer but I mean I think you have the
freedom of freedom of religion anyway
and also the Constitution the state
constitution rision is also like so that
uh people aren't citizens aren't um
subsidizing being forced to subsidize
somebody else's religion which I believe
is this current
situation that answer your question but
thanks are there further questions from
the
committee not seeing any any further
cards red card pink cards out there none
coming in
so only one so with that I so with that
we're going to close this hearing on
than you on HB 549 thank you so I have a
question for oh for you about can what
can we do to make sure we get people
here from the Department of Education
session for which work session well the
one there's one next week oh that that
that s yes they've already been
contacted yeah yeah yeah I thought you
were referencing this okay no no the the
the Department's already commun uh been
contacted regarding what's going on on
Friday next week on Thursday we are
looking at four bills which deal
specifically with special
education couple catastrophic bills or
special education Aid and the others on
the other side of the coin on
differentiated Aid uh that portion of it
we will be starting that on on uh all
all that morning on Friday morning there
will be a work session for that topic
we'll be doing similar type work
sessions and I'm not saying that's the
end of it either for the special Ed
because the catastrophic Aid is one
where I also have this evening a
teleconference call with a individual in
Arkansas which is in charge of the
catastrophic uh program down there and
trying to find out they have some
interesting Financial ways of handling
that a little different than how we do
it with 70 grand up top for the district
and then going on with the 2080 right up
through the 10 times that comes out
little sh of $100,000 you have to put
forth immediately as as a
town and they are putting forward a
system where the first $155,000 is on
the town from 15 to
$65,000 it's 100% on the state and from
65% on up to I I'm I'm estimating from
doing the reading through the lines
here's about $ 110
$120,000 there's a combination between
State and uh local but going beyond that
the state has a
cap and that's just one system that I've
looked at you can find these on the
education Commission of the states and
so I've had our research gen do some
contacting and we're trying to set up a
a system where we can get this
information and find out is there
another way of handling this because we
have bills coming in oh drop it a 3% or
three times drop it a two times what's
the difference well we trying to get a
handle on what type numbers of kids
that's dealing with and then we've also
have other forms coming in where we're
change that pration rate where you prate
the monies if you're not meeting that uh
$34 million and it's coming out 51 point
something uh you have to make that $17
million up well we prate it and now
we're prorating somewhere around 67 68%
right now we've done that in the past we
did it back in
2013 we climbed out of it and we've
recently been funding pretty much all of
it however it's it's we haven't done
that this year for whatever reason I
don't know but uh we cannot continue
like this districts cannot handle this
it's it's a cost it's just hitting them
boom like hitting a brick wall and so
there probably will be further
conversations on this we have the whole
month of February where we're going to
be working on this and there's going to
be a lot of work
sessions and then we tackle the other
subjects which we have and you know what
they are um those are going to be just
as difficult uh seeing that we're
hearing departments being told right now
cut it 4% cut at 8% cut it 10% cut it
14% um
that has to be dealt with um if we if we
have to do that if we have to do that if
Revenue say that's where we go
then we're going to we're going to have
to make some decisions here from this
education funding policy
side how do we prioritize
that so I I see this as you know and and
those people coming over to where
borrowing from Finance we appreciate
their support and help in doing that and
the people that coming that had
experience on ways and means there's
several here right now um we got to look
at every so that that's what's I'll tell
you this is the program these are the
programs which are bothering me the
most because they hit everybody in this
state and they hit our
Workforce and so it's a it's a
challenge yeah can you you've got a we
may have exact sections next Tuesday I
think on there we put that on the bottom
there I always work with the ranking
representative who's not here
and we try to find those bills which we
can
pass with a majority or very close to a
majority maybe one shallow or something
like that but by doing that I'm also
cognizant that for those District
committees to put that little line
underneath you always had to worry about
getting substitutes for your committee
that's a costly deal yeah and so if if
you know
that we'll let you know through your
ranking or through you know the vice
chair right here which ones we're going
to attack there's some bills we know
with a proper Amendment we're going to
get those things out of here and and we
can get it out with a strong vote
hopefully get them on consent if not get
them leased onto the calendar where we
know we can debate them on the floor I
I'm just I'm collecting all kinds of
material on uh due process from the
University system I was just I'm not
being controversial I just that will
probably come in because you you made a
comment uh last time that you're going
to try to get the early bills out oh not
try we got to yeah okay March 6 is our
date there and when we when I went back
to the desk last night and found nine
new early bills sitting on top of us or
not nine it was 12 or 11 or 12 yeah and
was wow okay and so we had to schedule
bills coming up in the calendar next
week before we knew about these other
early bills coming at us so you're going
to see some other bills on there that
are bills which are more or less
strictly policy from the CTE and the HD
uh which we should be able to get
through but they take time for every
hearing there's an executive session I
know so I'm I'm trying to get these
early bills done first now they some
today which weren't early bills but they
were the bills which were left over of
those first bills there's only one that
we haven't done but we now have a slug
of others saying we have 40 bills out
there I just have to tell a kennel when
I'm picking up my dog that's all yeah
so so yeah so uh we will have work
sessions that was the whole concept
behind this but I want to have the work
sessions first for the bills I know
we've got to do something with and I
know we have to be respectful those
towns which are not with the money to do
what we think they can we got to be
asking those good questions why are you
unable to do that is it because of the
dollar sign or is it possibly because of
the aspiration of the community or your
school board or you know all those other
issues which can you know impact
attitudes and all that the stuff that
you can't buy with your dollar sign uh
that that's a real Factor I've seen that
in
schools uh how there some of it is
leadership and so so we got our work cut
out for us and I just hope we can stick
together and just try to get our
priorities together rather than trying
to tackle everything with equal amount
of time we learned last year those bills
come out with no recommendation you
can't fix them you go through everything
octopath itl this and this and this you
finally come out no recommendation get
in the floor and you hammer it out again
and then somebody gets up let's table it
you know all those hours spent and days
spent on this stuff we could have been
using for the things we need to be doing
not that we shouldn't be doing that
other stuff but where we know we can get
the
compromise I I'm a firm believer that
legislation legislator can be very
effective I saw it happen when I first
got on board
here and it was one where we sat
together we went out to lunch together
and but we all knew where we stood but
we Tred to work and find that common end
we did on a lot of bills we really did
um it's it's sort of gone the that other
direction and not just in the last
several years it it's been gradually
happening represent McGuire and thank
you Mr chairman so um I a few remarks on
all this schle and so on um I really
appreciate your um pushing us to
emphasize those bills that that are
likely to to uh to pass or maybe close
to not passing but but sort of the ones
that that um have a chance right because
um and not spend a lot of time on those
that don't um just because myself and my
two colleagues who haven't been here
much um we get really busy 3 weeks from
now so and I will push them I will talk
to them and push them to join us for the
next 3 weeks so that we have you know
we're more at full strength um my
question to you was
um do you plan when we were doing this
work session uh phase to uh split into
subcommittees or to be generally
speaking a full committee on all the
bills that's a a very good question uh
I've always as I said at the very
beginning I
always done uh with this committee the
education policy Committee in the past
when we've had an opportunity I like
Committee of the whole however um there
have been times to when we dealt with I
can remember a bill years ago when we
went to concussion injury amongst our
athletes on the field and we broke that
down into a smaller subgroup about five
people we invited people in from the FL
and we we took testimony as we went down
the road it took us about 3 years to get
that bill finally where we wanted to get
it after talking with the nursing
associations and and Sports nhia Group
and in schools and administrators and
teachers and parents and trying to find
when is advisable what conditions do you
need to get the kid back on the field of
course you need a doctor they said a
doctor's permission I said you also need
the parents permission
and so we got great Bill small group
though it was a working group and
represent McGuire I know that you're
used to working like on those divisions
up in finance which are small groups to
begin with but um here we're we're we
got the task of also looking at policy
and fiscal side as well to send it on to
these guys right there that are going to
be able to not spend as much time on the
policy side because they've often times
done the work that we should do and and
they've ended up spending their wheels
when in fact they have the big picture
of hb1 staring them in the face and
that's what this bium this year is all
about so we will have undoubtedly on
some groups we may split it up small so
we can do two things at one time the the
counter to that is there's some folks
there are some people that counter to
having two education committees because
they felt well that's going to
something's going to go on there and I
don't know about and I want to stay a
breast of that so I can be knowledgeable
when I'm working later on I get it and
so it's and also when we have the
committee a whole sometimes we don't get
people coming and and then it whittles
down to a smaller group anyways but I
there I sometimes I've asked who wants
to be on it by the hands pop up from all
over the place um so it's I'm going to
have to work that one out some will be
small some are going to be the whole
and you know there's when we're talking
about
Finance that's where for example a
person would dick ames's background
would be very very valuable Sally you've
got a whole background on how things
worked over at the
department that history is going to be
necessary right now if we have to do a
lot of cutting we're going to have to
know where we got can and where this
funding's coming from Ways and Means
so so if you don't get put on something
believe me you'll be put on something
else and I can remember when I first got
on board Mary guile was one of them um
uh representative Rouse was there prior
to Mary but um Emma but uh the she would
stand sit right here and say okay I am
putting on it these five people well
bing bing bing bing bing you know three
dams and two Republicans she made that
mind up I I also want to find out before
we do that whether for example Sally
fellows is going to be available to be
one of those five people and so I I have
to do that chatting and that's where I
work with with the ranking Democrat
right here and and and I would be
working with a vice chair trying to find
out who who they recommend to so it's
just not Rick lad making these decisions
alone so I don't have all those
answers anything else for the good of
the order right now any other Pearls of
Wisdom I guess you're ready to go home
and have a good
weekend thank you for coming today it's
not easy on a Friday and thank you
representative Oregon you know it's not
easy coming you know I scheduled it
there just simply because it could have
been a whole load of people like as you
mentioned the beginning and or it went
the other way um hard to predict it's
hard to predict yeah